pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une réussite dans l'ombre de claude
lelouch mais c'est néanmoins une
réussite éclatante
depuis un homme une femme et puis
maintenant la fameuse chanson de love
story dont catherine de sages qui est à
votre droite a écrit les les paroles
est-ce que c'est aussi votre avis est-ce
que vous devez tout à claude lelouch
je crois que ça a été une des grandes
chances de rencontrer de toute façon je
pense que toutes les rencontres que j'ai
eues ont été bénéfiques et celle de
lelouch a été très importante puisque il
m'a permis justement de faire ma
première musique de film mais j'ai
rencontré claude lelouch par pierre
barrau avec qui j'ai écrit vais déjà des
chansons et comme lellouche voulais des
chansons dans son film c'est comme ça
que j'ai fait cette première musique
mais après une réussite aussi éclatante
que la vôtre maintenant après la musique
d'un homme une femme de loft story
on a envie de vous demander qui a t-il
après je n'en sais rien moi même je
pense que l'avenir le dira le dire a de
toute façon je pense que là une chose
que nous sommes en train de travailler
justement avec claude lelouch c'est une
comédie musicale pour le cinéma et
c'est finalement c'est le rêve de tout
compositeur
[Musique]